We want to be able to calculate
the total value of a portfolio
day by day by day.
Once we have that information,
then we can compute statistics
on the overall portfolio.
So let's start with an example.
Assume we start with a portfolio
value of one million dollars, and
we're going to take a look
at that portfolio from
the beginning of 2009
to the end of 2011.
And our portfolio consists of
these three symbols, S&P 500,
XOM, Google, and Gold.
And at the beginning of 2009,
we're going to allocate .4 or
40% of our portfolio to SPY,
40% to XOM, 10% to Google, and
10% to Gold, and we'll enter
those positions in the beginning,
and we'll hold them,
and step forward, and
see what the overall value of
the portfolio is day by day.
How do we calculate the total
value of the portfolio day by day?
Here's how to do it step by step.
We start with our prices data frame.
Remember the four columns with
prices every day, indexed by date.
The first step is to
normalize these prices.
As we've done before, it is just the
price values divided by the first row.
So after we normalize, we have
a new data frame, normed, which is,
as we said,
all the prices divided by the first row.
That's going to give us now this
new data frame where the first row
all 1.0 and then it proceeds after that.
And these are essentially cumulative
returns starting from the start date.
The next step is to multiply
these normed values
by the allocations to
each of the equities.
So we'll just multiply normed
times our allocations, allocs, and
that gives us a new data frame alloced.
Now as you remember,
our allocations were 0.4, 0.4, 0.1, 0.1.
So when we do that multiplication,
the first row is going to
represent those numbers.
And the data after the first
row will be sized accordingly.
Our next step is to multiply our
alloc data frame times start_val.
And what that'll give us is,
in this first row the amount of
cash allocated to each asset and
then going forward, it'll show us
the value of that asset over time.
So we've got now a new data frame,
pos_vals, what that means is position
values, that at each day,
that's how much that position is worth.
So we started out, for instance, with
400,000 for the first one, 400,000 for
the second one, 100,000, 100,000.
But now as we go forward each day,
it's as if we invested say
100,000 in this one, and it reflects how
much it was worth each day after that.
Now that we have the value each day for
the individual assets, we can calculate
the total value for the portfolio
each day by summing across each day.
So on the first day for
instance the value of the portfolio was
four hundred thousand plus four hundred
thousand plus one hundred plus one
hundred thousand or one million.
Now those values change of course as
the stock prices change going forward.
So each day is a little bit different.
We can calculate the value for
each of these days by taking the sum
of pos_vals,
position vals using axis=1, so
that's telling python to sum
across each row like that.
So that sums each day
across into Port_val,
which now reflects the value each
day for our total portfolio.
Let's recap now.
We start with our prices.
We normalize that to the first day,
so the first row here is all ones.
We multiply it times our allocations,
and that gives us now in each column,
the relative value of each
of those aspects over time.
We multiply by our initial investment,
and
that causes now each row to be
the real value of that investment
each day over time,
starting with our initial allocations.
If we then sum each row
we get the value of the portfolio on
each corresponding day, and that's it.
That's how you calculate
daily portfolio value.